we were then fortunate to go to the
American Embassy way at jackman
the ambassador and he started unpacking
for us what was going on in the world
which was his surrounding us and he's
been doing that ever since that he left
before we retired from the Park Service
basically when when the sodium thank you
and it's had a series of academic
appointments at Columbia initially and
then at Princeton in the Kenan chair at
the Center for Advanced Study when he's
produced a series of books on the
post-cold war world on Russia and
related subjects and he's here today
giving the second of four lectures on
forthcoming book from Yelp restful
distorting history misunderstanding the
Cold War is undermined America's
leadership in the changing its security
today to talk about the 90s democracy
would disarray and not further ado I
turn things over to ambassador my father
thank you very much thank you very much
professor Shapiro and once again I would
say I'm quite honored to be able to
deliver another lecture in the name of
the Henry Simpson series of lectures
those of you who were here yesterday at
the lecture must have been a little
confused when I referred to the
quotations on a sheet that I had assumed
had been handed out turned out it wasn't
handed out but today I think you have it
and those quotations I will be referring
to off and on during the presentation
some of them i agree with some other i
don't agree with but all of them are I
would say fairly well known generally
known comments on Russia that have been
made
in the nineteenth and twentieth
centuries the earliest being a
well-known quotation by the tofu which
comes from the end of his first volume
of democracy in america and the
quotation that I've really taken to be
you might say the keynote theme of all
four lectures but the specific subject
of the fourth is the one from from steps
in himself his communication to Truman
when he said we must find some way of
persuading Russia to play ball now
obviously this was 1945 the war was just
ending I hadn't yet ended in the Pacific
but it was clear to Stimpson at that
time that we were not going to have the
sort of international order the sort of
post-world War to World if the Soviet
Union didn't cooperate he called it
Russia then and that's another thing I
wanted to distinguish because when we
talk about Russia we have to bear in
mind which Russia so often whether we
referring to Soviet Union or Thoris
Russia are the present Russian
Federation we refer just to Russia as if
this was the same body and as I pointed
out yesterday Russia has actually gone
through four different sort of
fundamentally different types of
governments over the last hundred years
a Czarist autocracy for a very very
brief period and embryonic parliamentary
system in 1917 then a communist Empire
not a Russian Empire because the Soviet
Union was not a though it occupied much
of the same territories as our east
empire it really was a communist empire
and ideologically an ideological empire
rather than
national empire and then we have the
Russian Federation of today which is
also multinational but much greater
proportion of ethnic Russians in fact
close to eighty percent ethnic Russian
where is in the Soviet Union toward the
end Russians were in a slight minority
also yesterday talked a bit about the
dangers of thinking in in terms of
opposites thinking in terms of well is
Russia Europe or something else is
Europe simply a synonym for a democratic
country with a market economy what does
it mean if we speak of something
European no we know what the European
Union is this is a concrete area and one
can I think speak intelligently about
relations with the European Union but
arguments over whether Russia is Europe
or European or not I find not very
productive because there is when you
generalize to the degree of the whole
continent you deprive it of most meaning
to be quite frank Spain is quite
different from Sweden and and grease
from the UK a lot of these are separate
cultures and when we put them all
together as if there is a uniform
culture there and Russia is not part of
it we really miss a lot of nuance Russia
to be sure is an answer to the question
I posed yesterday sua generis but so is
every other country and we've got to get
beyond sort of the the contrast that we
often put in sort of a theoretical way
well let's pick up today in the 1990s
the time when the Soviet Union broke up
and the Russian Federation the largest
of its successor States
went through its first decade of
existence as I mentioned in the end
yesterday I thought the world had seen
three geopolitically seismic events that
experienced them in the late 1980s the
very early 1990s one was the end of the
Cold War and that ended well before the
Soviet Union collapsed one of the
problems people have sometimes is simply
fusing the two assuming that somehow the
end of the Cold War occurred when the
Soviet Union collapsed absolutely wrong
the Cold War ended as a result of
cooperation between the United States
and the Soviet Union and also between
the United States and its allies and the
Soviet leader it was a negotiated end
and it was not anything resembling a
military victory if someone thought it
did in on terms that had been set by the
United States and its allies but these
terms were calculated to be in the
interest of a Soviet Union which would
live in peace with its neighbors and not
try to expand and force itself upon
others and it was in the interests of
the Soviet leaders to accept these terms
so everything Gorbachev did was in the
interest of the Soviet Union and when he
says we all won the Cold War I would
agree then you had the end of communist
rule in the Soviet Union this is not
something that was brought down by
Western pressure it was brought down
into communist rule by the manipulation
of the General Secretary of the
Communist Party of the Soviet Union
Mikhail Gorbachev who took the party out
of control of the country when he saw
that the party was blocking the reforms
that he wanted to have and then at the
end of 91 we saw the Soviet Union itself
break up peacefully except for some
conflict around
the periphery of remarkable event I
think that many historians I've heard
have said you know they can't think of
another occasion where an empire of that
size and so on just peacefully broke up
now was this the result of Western
pressure was this part of the so-called
victory over the Cold War absolutely not
this was caused by internal forces in
the Soviet Union and the idea that
somehow it was us pressure particularly
military or economic pressure that
brought down the Soviet Union gets it
backwards the American government tried
to help Gorbachev preserve a voluntary
union in those last month's we were
unable to do it we did not see I'm
speaking we American official that it
was in our interest to have the Soviet
Union break up we wanted it to change we
want it but and we wanted the three
Baltic States which we had never
recognized as part of the Soviet Union
to be given their independence again but
the other 12 republics we would have
been more comfortable seeing them agree
to a voluntary union and a President
Bush the elder made that clear in a
speech in Kiev august first 1991 well it
didn't happen and yet since then myths
have developed which I think have
confused not only us but particularly
Russians and most Russians today would
say well the western United States in
particular brought down the Soviet Union
in order to dominate us and many of the
pictures one gives one sees here support
that sort of myth how many times when
you see some portrayal of the Berlin
Wall being taken down is it preceded by
an image of Ronald Reagan sandy
in front of the Brandenburg Gate and
saying mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
and then the next image is of the wall
coming down there was no cause and
effect of course we wanted the wall to
come down because that was part of it
but Reagan made that speech in 1987 at a
time when we were still trying to get at
that point a treaty on nuclear weapons
signed was signed in December of that
year but Reagan politically was trying
to recover from from the iran-contra
caper which damaged him politically and
he was going to be leading us in to
signing a major treaty and persuading he
hoped the Senate to ratify it he had to
be shown as still firmly anti-communist
now did that bring down the wall well no
actually the wall came down a couple of
years later and after quite different
things happened mindful of Reagan's
speech which got a lot of concern the
next year actually in 1989 the first
year that George Bush the elder was
present Bush planned a trip to eastern
europe gorbachev was very concerned that
there would be some of the same type of
rhetoric which actually if there had
been would have made it much more
difficult to do what he was trying to do
he was in pressuring the the East
Europeans including the East Germans to
reform the sort of reforms that could
well bring down the wall now if the
American president is traveling in the
area and making speeches like that that
makes it very politically difficult so
Gorbachev took me aside
at a social occasion and said you know
would you tell my friend George by that
time they were on a first-name basis
could be a little more considerate the
worse and wordless venema chimney which
can also mean attentive but in this
context it was considerate and I said
well you know what are you have in mind
and he said no just telling that well I
sent the message and and Bush took it to
heart he traveled in through the various
several East European countries not a
word of direct criticism about the
soviet union after he left the visit
chevre nods e the foreign ministry
called me over i was over on another
matter and he said by the way President
Gorbachev wants President Bush to know
that he appreciates the way he handled
his trip in Eastern Europe in other
words once we stopped the rhetoric and
pound it down and Gorbachev with his
reforms started the process that
eventually brought the wall down but it
was not mr. Gorbachev who tear down that
wall it was the Germans that tore down
that wall and that's another thing that
I would say juxtaposing these two images
as if there was cause and effect leaves
entirely the wrong impression pardon me
for going into such detail but I did
want to get across the idea that some of
these myths that we have about how the
Cold War ended and what it means really
twisted in a way which I think has
turned out to be dangerous for our own
foreign policy now George Bush besides
on the one hand keeping the rhetoric
cool regarding Eastern Europe and you
may recall that when he was asked why he
didn't say more about the Berlin Wall
coming down he said I'm not going to go
dance on the wall I'm not going to make
political capital out of this and this
was actually one of the essential thing
keep these reforms going if the American
president had started crowing about it
look we're forced him to do this forced
him to do that that process might have
stopped right off well we didn't so we
saw during the Bush administration first
of all a confirmation that the Cold War
was really over philosophically I think
it was over when Gorbachev gave a speech
at the United Nations in December 1988
because in that speech he renounced
implicitly the class international class
struggle as the foundation of Soviet
foreign policy and explicitly reversed
the Brezhnev Doctrine by saying that
every country should have an untrammeled
right an unrestricted right to decide
its form of government that of course
was the opposite of the Soviet attitude
in the Brezhnev Doctrine where if a
country had was what socialist it was
the obligation of other socialist
countries to keep counter-revolution
from removing it and as a result you've
got the invasions of hungry of
Czechoslovakia of Afghanistan and in
succession but the bush continued many
of the policies that had been had been
enunciated during the Reagan
administration and we we got several
major arms control agreements most
significantly geopolitically was that he
was able to negotiate Soviet support in
the United Nations to authorize the war
to liberate Kuwait the first Gulf War
one of the greatest contrasts in
diplomacy if you want to make a
comparison is what we did diplomatically
before the first Gulf War and what we
didn't do diplomatically when we invaded
Iraq in two thousand and was it three
now
in any event that took fairly intense
diplomacy and I won't delay us with with
all of the the details at this point
except to say that it was diplomacy and
that there was no reason to assume at
the beginning of that that when Saddam
Hussein advanced indica weight and took
it over that the Soviet Union was not
going to support Saddam Hussein he had
been there a lie they had armed him
there were over 8,000 Soviet specialists
for the military equipment then in Iraq
and persuading them to condemn this and
then vote in the UN to use all necessary
means I think that was the phrase to
remove Iraqi troops from Kuwait I think
was a diplomatic achievement of great
moment it was really Secretary of State
Baker Jim Baker who who did most of the
actual diplomacy but the fact is that
this told us something that many of us
had already felt after Gorbachev speech
and other actions that is the Cold War
really was over and when you have them
you know authorizing the United States
to lead a coalition against one of the
Earth's while allies that shows that
things have changed and changed pretty
drastically now as East Europe liberated
itself the Berlin Wall came down the
question immediately arose what happens
to Germany
it was one thing for a Soviet government
to allow countries that had been
communist to throw out their communist
governments but it was another thing to
allow the two German states which for
many Soviet citizens the fact that
Germany was divided and that they in
effect control the eastern part one of
the primary evidences that they won
World War two and suddenly the question
was will you give that up the big issue
really was not so much will there be
unity at some point but under what
conditions at first the first few weeks
after the Berlin Wall came down the
Soviet leaders really seemed to think
that you could get a you know a more
liberal communist regime in the German
Democratic Republic which could hold on
at least for a while and as they put it
you know unification is an issue for the
future they thought it didn't have to
happen on their watch and i would say in
early december 89 this really was the
attitude i recall calling on Shara not
see the Foreign Minister just after we
got back to Moscow from the summit
meeting in Malta that Bush had had and I
asked him about German unification he
said well you know we think it's going
to happen in the future but it is a
question for the future later that month
I called on ambassador fallen who had
been their ambassador in west germany
and and then was head of the
International Department of the Central
Committee and I asked him the same
question and he said we thought this was
going to be a question for the future
but we see it is one that's going to be
resolved now this was in the course of
December in
space of about three weeks and but at
that point they made two conditions they
wanted first of all they wanted the
unity to be negotiated between the two
German states and second that therefore
it be a negotiated settlement assuming
that the government in the East Germany
would in effect represent their
interests and the second was that if
there was German unity Germany had to
leave neat NATO you could not have a
united Germany in NATO and this became a
crucial issue now the matter of
negotiation by the two German states
became moot after the Christian
Democrats won the election in East
Germany in early March of of 1990 but
the question of a united Germany in NATO
remained very much their and Baker
addressed this question directly with
Gorbachev in February 90 when he posed a
question which he said look I want you
to think about this you don't have to
give me an immediate answer but assuming
there is no expansion of NATO
jurisdiction to the east not one inch
wouldn't it be better to have a united
Germany anchored in NATO with all of the
implications that that has then one
which is free in the future to go its
own way now he didn't say specifically
to go nuclear to get nuclear weapons
this was clearly what he had in mind and
he added NATO is the only legal reason
we have troops in Europe most Europeans
feel that this helps stabilize the
situation again he didn't say keep
Germany under control but that's what he
meant and wouldn't we all be better off
if that continues Gorbachev answer was
of course any expansion
nato to the east would be unacceptable
but the other point you make a very
important and I'm going to take them
seriously and then he added as far as
American presence in Europe I want you
to know we are not trying to expel you
from Europe anymore there was one time
that was part of our policy but we
recognize that an American military
present can be stabilizing said no you
know you probably don't need 300,000
troops but we'd like to see you know
fewer but we understand that you have a
role to play and we want you here I told
the Baker's we were riding back to the
embassy you've got him you know he's
going to buy this but the point I'm
making now is he bought this with
understanding no expansion to the east
will let Germany stay in well the
details were worked out later they're
other details here which I won't go into
now essentially when Baker made the
statement he also had in mind that even
the territory of the German Democratic
Republic would not be an 80 he had come
through bond had talked to foreign
minister ginter and it was against yours
idea when Baker got back to Washington
it turned out that the lawyers told him
look that's it you can't do that so
later in our negotiations that was made
clear that the GDR territory would
become part of NATO and this was made
clear in the negotiations but his
initial statement was a very flat when
he didn't limit it to the GDR and and
yet Gorbachev never asked for any formal
assurance maybe none could have been
given but I can testify as one who was
very much involved in some of these
negotiations it didn't cross any of our
minds at that time that the United
States whatever or west europe would
ever find it in its interest to expand
nato to the east now this is the
perspective of 1990 now the
this was really an implicit deal with
Gorbachev and it was carried over with
Yeltsin as long as the Bush
administration was in power the Soviet
Union collapsed even though the bush had
tried to give a voluntary Union a push
Bush was able very quickly to bond with
Yeltsin to the point that when I visited
Yeltsin researching my book on the
Soviet collapse in October of of 1992
one of the first things he said is till
my friend George I'm praying that he'll
win the election I was able to tell him
that well you know if the polls hold he
may not but i believe the next president
will be equally equally friendly to
russia but at that time he i would say
at bush and Yeltsin were able to develop
a relationship just about as
confidential and and confident as the
one that Bush had with Gorbachev after
the Soviet Union collapsed Russia went
through simultaneously three profound
revolutions again I don't know that one
can find another and insert another
large country that has been confronted
simultaneously with such a radical
change there was a political revolution
replacing the Communist Party with what
was at least formally a democratic
system an elected system with a real
legislature with at least theoretically
independent judiciary and so on and
simply replacing the sort of rule they
had under the Communists which as I
mentioned yesterday
a was like a criminal organization
ruling the country through a front
organization which happened to be the
formal government instead the elected
government became the real government to
the degree it was a government 180
degree turn economics from a totally
state controlled economy they went to a
market economy from an economy where
everything had been planned in the
center where it was illegal to own any
property that was used to make a profit
he could only own certain very limited
personal property and and it was illegal
to sell something for more than you paid
for it that was speculation it was
illegal to hire somebody to do work for
you because that was exploitation and
only the state could do these things and
suddenly you get the opposite and and
you get a sudden attempt at
privatization in a country where there
was no legitimate private capital how do
you do that what private capital there
was it was from the black market and
well what happened in effect was those
who had access maybe because of their
party connections maybe because of the
KGB connections maybe because of their
military connections grab what they
could and for the average person it was
a total disaster inflation in 1992 was a
couple of thousand percent in effect
savings were wiped out the average
person did have savings pensions were
very low and even people toward the
bottom of the scale would have saved a
few thousand rules for
their old age and suddenly this became
worthless not only that the government
didn't have enough money even to pay the
pensions often nor did many of the
employers you had sometimes going months
without people getting paid and perhaps
the so you had a political revolution an
economic revolution but the one that
maybe was deepest was the revolution
that had to do with the self-image what
does it mean to be Russian it's an
ethnic term he said a political term has
Russian lost half its people because
it's naturally an empire or have the
Russian people find a gain control of
their destiny which before had been in
the hands of this ideological empire and
the interesting thing is that often
these conflicting views existed in the
breast of the same person it wasn't just
some groups thought one and other groups
off the other it was a real feeling of
you know what what what does it mean to
be Russian something that for example I
think a Chinese would never question I
think Richard never questioned what it
means to be French any question but you
really had a period of considerable
self-doubt and so on and whether what
had happened was good at first you know
getting the communist party out of power
was extraordinarily popular and then
suddenly you have chaos you lose your
job the institutions are not there
things that were a crime before are now
required to get along and what's more
the president starts fighting with the
parliament in 1993 at one point the
tension got so strong that the leaders
of parliament operating actually without
a quorum because some who were favorable
to President Yeltsin left then actually
tried to take
the government by force occupying the
mayor's office and then attacking the
television tower until Yeltsin brought
in our army unit and shall the
Parliament not a pretty picture I was
shortly after that I was in Moscow and
being interviewed and I was asked could
you imagine the American president ever
shelling the Congress and I said no but
I can't imagine the Congress trying to
raise an army and take over Washington
you know these things just are not
supposed to happen but what really what
Russian saw in the 90s after the fall of
the Soviet Union was instability
bordering on anarchy the spread of
organized crime and bureaucratic
corruption it was truly a Hobbesian
world and success seemed he required to
see lack of scruples and not just a
matter of using your elbows but going
even further than that doing in your
associates and neighbors the economy was
near collapse state assets and
everything had been state-owned tended
to be simply stolen and I've already
mentioned the non-payment of wages and
pensions and the disappearances of
savings so the impact I think on those
Russian opinion was very very strong
people said this is democracy and if you
you know since then they've been a
number of poles and you'll find that
Russians would say by considerable
majority they don't want democracy now
if you ask them do you want to be able
to vote for your government do we want
to be able to travel freely do you want
if you break it down two things you'll
get overwhelming yes on all of those
things but democracy too many means the
chaos in your Anarchy which they
experienced in the nineties
you know even before the night is I
think this was in late 90 or 91 Rebecca
and I were in the Crimea we had a visit
of an American naval ship first time
since World War two and one of the
officers of the Black Sea Fleet took us
on a cutter along the coast of the
Crimea and we stopped in the Alta and
the mayor took us around town and there
it was a nice summer day nice and warm
and people were out swimming in the
Black Sea but there was an area in the
beach with a big sign up danger no
swimming there must have been 20 people
in that area swimming and I asked the
mayor well you know don't you enforce
your safety rules and he said oh we have
democracy now we can't tell people what
to do so somehow the idea what democracy
was you know came to be you know just
anything goes now what about American
policy during this period of the
nineties and how it you might say
interacted with what was happening in
Russia I might say that a very good book
i think on on the policy which looks at
it I think in depth from the American
point of view is a recent one by James
goldeyer and Michael McFaul that's
called power and purpose very insightful
on American on the American side I think
somewhat less so on the Russian side and
they make it clear in their introduction
that their emphasis has been on the
American side so those who want to
pursue this in detail I can certainly
recommend that as sort of a a very good
text in hitting the main points well at
first with President Clinton you had a
talk of a partnership with Russia for at
least a partnership for reform there was
immediate reaction back here premature
partnership they're not worthy of it etc
they're not ready for it but
increasingly although President Clinton
tried to maintain good
relations with Yeltsin and generally
could get his way with Yeltsin Yeltsin
increasingly weak politically in Russia
needed the American support if he had
lost that you know things could have
gotten very mid so in that sense I think
Clinton was able in effect to roll
Yeltsin and to push him on always every
point that we thought was important to
us or to others but in effect we started
treating Russia as a defeated country
there was a strong feeling of
triumphalism we won the Cold War some of
the commentators when issues would come
up we'll say you know we won the co or
we can do what we want Russia doesn't
count anymore oh look how disorderly
they are their army is worth nothing
they can't even bring order to Chechnya
and that one of their smallest provinces
and you know we can ignore them and that
really seemed to be the attitude Oh what
economic advice we gave was not all that
great quite frankly we were already
becoming enamored of a sort of market
supremacy you know just get your
property in private hands and establish
a market economy and everything's going
to be fine and keep the government out
of it the last thing you want is any
government intervention well you know
the Russians were there they're grown
they're adults they what if they took
the advice it's their responsibility but
frankly much of the advice was not
really very well suited for conditions
that they had and the particularly the
way they went through the privatization
which turned out to be more a matter of
theft than a matter of what we would
consider privatization that is the
private sector buying state assets at
you know more or less market prices and
you didn't have a private sector that
legal one that to buy this stuff
and of course the whole privatization
came to be called in Russian peccatis at
sia russia has the same loan word that
we do for privatization privadas oncea
but who i thought you in russian is to
grab sobriquet Assad CEO was gravitation
the the asset seemed to be up for grabs
and it was United States and Wes that
was endorsing all of this even
encouraging it in their eyes well so
gradually what turned out from the early
nineties polls that showed that eighty
percent or more of the Russian people
considered the United States the most
admired country in the world the country
to which they would like to aspire by
the end of the 90s at the time we were
bombing Serbia over Kosovo the polls
were exactly the opposite with eighty
percent saying the United States was the
most dangerous country in the world now
i want to point this out because this
change in opinion occurred before
vladimir putin it occurred in the 90s it
occurred when there was still talk of
Russia being in a transition to
democracy and it was a time when the
freedoms in Russia in many respects were
greater than they are today but even
then they were not greater than they
were in the last year of the Soviet
Union that last year of Gorbachev people
were even freer than they were in a nice
because they were still was at least
some semblance of order rather than the
sort of chaos they had in the 90s but
then in the late nineties United States
in my opinion made some strategic
blunders one was the decision for NATO
enlargement that's the reason I spend as
much time as I do on the Bush
administration cultivation of Gorbachev
and leaving the impression which was a
genuine one that if they left Eastern
Europe
they let them go we were not going to
seem to take advantage of that
geopolitically by simply moving in and
military alliance I would say by the way
the Russians have not objected to the
enlargement of the European Union
perhaps that's even more important
certainly is more important to the
Central and East Europeans than the NATO
but they do see NATO as a military
alliance despite the various changes
that have occurred since the war and
military alliance commanded by the
United States and such agreements as
they have with NATO doesn't really seem
to give them a voice when it comes to
decisions that affect them now this was
all quite predictable I was one of a
number of people who very strongly
advised against moving NATO enlargement
that way the question was not whether we
should find a way to reassure the poles
and the checks and the other East
Europeans and the three Baltic states
that we would protect them from future
aggression there were a number of ways
that could be done and even the Russians
told us officially look if you want to
extend NATO guarantees to these
countries fine if you want to have the
partnership of peace cooperation or the
military that's fine what really we have
to object to is bringing them in to a
central military alliance in which their
military is actually becomes part of an
overall American commanded military
establishment and yet that is precisely
what was done now when we did it we said
you don't have to worry good heavens
this is this is a purely defensive
alliance and we know you're not
threatening these countries and we we
have no doubt that you are going to
throw you're not going to threaten them
in the future so why should you worry
NATO is constitutionally in
capable of an offensive operation and
what happens in 1999 when we couldn't
get a vote in the United Nations to use
military force to protect the Kosovars
NATO without un approval decides to
bombed Serbia now mind you not to send
in troops to protect the Kosovars but to
make war against Serbia and the Russian
had to say you know what's going on this
is your defensive alliance you're using
it as a substitute for the UN now the
problem with this diplomacy is if we had
not expanded they tow if we had found
other mechanisms for reassuring the East
Europeans and most of all had encouraged
the EU to bring them into that economic
arrangement which they certainly needed
almost certainly Russia number one would
have pressured Milosevic to cool it in
Kosovo and give them their or failing
that would have voted with us in the UN
to authorize it so you know one thing
sort of led to another and at this point
the the Russians of course began to look
at very great skepticism at the American
claims and but the message overall I
think was a more general one is that
we're not going to accept you as equals
we're not going to accept you in the
West we're not going to treat you like
we do the other Europeans we consider
you a threat because you're weak then if
we think about the whole nuclear policy
what was the central issue during the
cold war with the Soviet Union nuclear
weapons the fact is that at the height
of the Cold War each of us probably had
enough weapons that if they were used
would have destroyed human life on earth
seven times over not once not twice each
others at one point that was probably an
existence something like sixty thousand
nuclear warheads well we were getting
the numbers down and both Gorbachev and
Reagan were united in one thing and that
was they should move the world toward
the elimination of nuclear weapons these
are weapons that simply have no rational
military use and that process had gotten
a pretty good start with Reagan and
Gorbachev and then with Bush the first
and Gorbachev we had a strategic arms
agreement signed which cut all the
strategic arms by 50% and destroyed them
with verification very strict
verification and then another agreement
was signed a start to in the last
month's of the of the Bush
administration the first Bush
administration and then everything sort
of stalled start to never really got
ratified it was so it the Duma Russian
Duma kept holding it up because of
things like NATO expansion because of
things like the bombing of Serbia and
finally they ratified only under
condition that the ABM treaty not be
disturbed and of course the second Bush
administration walked out of the ABM
treaty which means that the second start
agreement never came into force the
first one by the way runs out this year
and has not been renewed we had a
program that was actually first pushed
by Congress by Senators nan and lugar
the so called non lugar program which
has been a very useful one with aid to
the safety
of nuclear weapons in Russia but the
fact is that both the United States and
Russia throughout the 90s and to this
day have thousands of nuclear warheads
on operational alert does it make any
sense they're not even any targets for
them and yet when you have them it's
sort of like riding a tiger yeah if you
take them off you in a ladder a what's
the other side going to do it they're
going to take advantage of it as far as
I can tell we have not since the first
Bush administration negotiated seriously
on those and on a number of other
nuclear issues and the so what remains
now is a standoff in a sense we do have
an agreement for further reductions that
was signed in 2002 by the second Bush
administration but it is an agreement
without any verification and also the
United States announced that well we
won't be destroying all these we take
off we're going to store some case we
need them in the future what we're going
to need them for in the future how do
you plan to use them and then the Bush
administration announced that well they
really needed to develop some new
nuclear weapons like weapons that could
attack underground facilities like the
sort that may exist in Iran well some of
this has been has not been funded by
Congress but the fact is we have gone
from a policy on both sides of moving
toward getting rid of these things and
yet today when nobody seems to be paying
any attention serious attention to this
issue the US and Russia still own nearly
ninety five percent of the existing
nuclear weapons in the world and yet
we're telling other countries you can't
have them and yet the non-proliferation
treaty obligates the countries with them
to move
them down the numbers down with a goal
of zero as part of their obligation so
when we are not dealing with this issue
how do we expect to deal with the
non-proliferation issue effectively well
this is a question and I'll get back to
it later when we when we look
particularly at the current situation
but to get to the question that the
title of my talk today was you know is
it democracy or disarray in the 90s one
we really have to say it was much more
disarray than amok recy and therefore
people who characterized and many of
them have the new developments in
Putin's Russia since he became president
in 2000 as backtracking on democracy and
this was actually a phrase used in one
of the working groups at the Council on
Foreign Relations had I would say come
on backtracking on democracy that wasn't
democracy it was true that in the
nineties in a formal sense they had
elections and it was fairly easy to get
a party registered and now it's not so
easy campaigning was quite open and so
on and actually as far as we can tell
the counting of the votes was reasonably
honest but did a person get the feeling
that their representative in the Duma
could do anything for them to represent
their interests most of them were bribed
by somebody else and and and even if
they hadn't been you know they didn't
they really weren't set up for the sort
of of constituent services that we're
accustomed to for example I asked one of
my friends who was elected to the Duma
twice
more Musk what he thought of Putin's
ruling at one point and he got the
Constitution actually changed for this
that all their representatives should be
elected on a party slate rather than
representing districts like our
congressman do originally in the Russian
Federation half the Duma members were
elected in constituencies and half on
party slates and then Putin said they
should all be on party slates well this
obviously if you control the parties
that have them then this enables you to
control the people represented and they
don't represent districts I thought my
friend would be outraged by this he said
Jack you know I had two terms there
there wasn't a thing I could do for my
constituents because that's not how the
system worked said unless you could work
through a party he was from one of the
smaller parties nothing got done so it
no it didn't benefit my constitutes it
didn't benefit me and he said maybe this
will be better because it will maybe
encourage more consolidation of the
parties well actually it's had a
different effect but I my point is that
what the Russians experienced was not a
very pleasant experience and it's quite
normal that it seems to me that they
turned against actually many of the
ideas of democracy and this leads me
also to speak a little bit and I know I
mentioned this yesterday as well about
what I would call the limitations of
freedom as an objective obviously this
is I think a very laudable American
desire to see other people free and I'm
em one who believes that most people do
want to be free but can people be free
if they don't know where the next meal
is coming from can they be free if
lawbreakers act without restraint
and the whole neighborhood is you know
it's controlled by mafia mobs whoo-hoo
if you get in debt to them and don't pay
off you'll lose your life how much
respect will they have for a political
system in which elected representatives
are powerless to act in their interests
and I so it means that if you look at
the sort of charts that freedom house
has and these are useful if they leave
out the economic performance the social
safety net even such things as low in
order on the streets you leave out a
very important element of people's
attitude toward their government and the
fact is that in terms of a safety net in
terms of avoiding after they got out
through Stalin's purges and so on
avoiding sort of mass lawlessness at the
local level the Soviets did a pretty
good job people at least they might have
limits and what they did there might be
many things in our lives that were more
directed but you know by the 70s the 80s
people were at least not falling through
the safety net in large numbers and life
was generally orderly and predictable
obviously if you feel oppressed you
predictability baby doesn't mean very
much but in the sort of situation
Russians faced in the 90s predictability
became or the lack of predictability
became one of the biggest complaints and
when Putin took office in two thousand
what can one say about Russian attitudes
first of all the feeling of defeat and
humiliation and what seemed to be
Western contempt or if not contempt even
possibly hostility was very general
they felt a rejection not only by the
East European countries and maybe the
harwich expected that but also by the
people in the Baltics and particularly
the Georgians I think for Russians the
fact that the Georgians begin treating
them as enemies was sort of the
unkindest cut of all because they had
the feeling that always treated the
Georgians well the Georgian nobility was
taken into the Russian nobility from the
time Georgia came part of the Russian
Empire in the early 19th century and
Georgians had played a very prominent
role including in the case of Stalin the
supreme leader so almost the insult to
their feeling of national integrity and
definition of them all when so many of
the non Russian nationals who seemed to
be turning against them I think was very
hard psychologically to take the
so-called democratic system simply
wasn't working future was uncertain
everything unpredictable now going back
to my theme yesterday is Russia east or
west european non-european by nature
authoritarian resistant to democracy and
democratic practices many people find
evidence for that but i would ask one
question if americans had experienced
what Russians did in the 1990s would
they have supported a more authoritarian
regime and we have a partial answer
after nine eleven a tragic occurrence
but one nowhere near as shattering or
threatening or humiliating that's what
Russians went through in the 90s we
found that Americans did acquiesce to
and in many cases support
more authoritarian practices by their
government so how different is Russia
when you look at the context when you
look at what they went through and how
they interpreted not entirely unfairly
what consider at best the indifference
at worse the hostility of the west which
they had aspired to become part of then
I think you do see a country that was
ready for Vladimir Putin and when I come
back in a couple of weeks we'll talk
about what happened then
some time for questions I'll be happy my
hearing is not very good so speak either
loud or professor Shapiro can repeat it
for me why do you think that the project
of enlarging NATO was resumed under the
Clinton administration which one might
thought would have been a rather less
caucus inclined one that is predecessors
you know um James gold Guyer one of the
co-authors of one of the books i
recommended wrote a whole book about
that called not whether but when i think
in my own opinion it was almost a
hundred percent domestic politics first
of all when the republicans won the
election in let's it would be 94 when
newt gingrich became a speaker one of
the points in the contract with america
was we should expand nato so you were
getting political pressure from the
republicans at that point these were not
the bush won republicans but the bush to
republicans i would say and I know that
when I would go up to Congress and
testify against it and testify the
reasons we shouldn't do this I would
often be taken aside by others who were
up and since get real there's no way
this administration is not going to go
for an expansion of NATO and this was
actually in 1996 he said look where the
East European votes are Pennsylvania
Illinois the polls particularly the
polls in the United States and also the
Ukrainians other used to appeal to all
gung-ho to get their countries in NATO
and they said you know Clinton if he
wins at 96 election it look easy
is going to be close he needs
Pennsylvania and Illinois you know
there's no way he's going to and that's
when he promised there that NATO it was
not whether but when and there were
probably other reasons too I know former
Senator Bill Bradley who also thinks
this was a huge mistake told me he
thought well and went beyond that that
Clinton was really looking for something
that looked like his own foreign policy
and since he was being pushed
politically that that was something to
do but it was clear that before that
when we developed the partnership for
peace where you could have a great
degree of military cooperation with the
partners without actually bringing them
in the alliance it looked as if this was
designed in order to allow NATO not to
expand but then suddenly you got the
decision and then everything else was
really set up and pre-arranged when Joe
Biden in the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee set up his hearings you always
had six to argue in favor and for office
to argue against it and later when he
spoke at the Council on Foreign
Relations he started out by saying you
know we've had more people testifying
for rather than against and then he
laughed and said well of course that
doesn't mean very much because we select
whom we invite but the thing is it would
the political fixer zone by both parties
and the basic reason was had much more
to do with internal politics than it did
with really a careful thought about what
the impact for our foreign policy is
going to be as i said the attitude was
heck we won the Cold War you know Russia
is defeated even though Russia wasn't
even a party to the Cold War Russia was
one of the colonies of the Soviet empire
and actually I know that yeltsin and the
Russian leaders helped us really work
closer to American policy than even
Gorbachev those last two years so they
helped us in the cold war with their
political influence but this is all
forgotten I would say that I think if
President Herbert Walker Bush had been
reelected I don't believe he would have
expanded NATO and his second term now
maybe his successor would have but I I
don't think he would have knowing that
uh there you know policies change in
administration's why was what was their
decision to not formalize the non
expansion data okay I didn't say why was
the agreement or non agreement that are
sorry why why did we decide not to
formalize the non expansion of data oh
we didn't decide not to formalize non
expansion of NATO Gorbachev never asked
us to formalize it I must say he had a
lot of things on his mind and I'm not
sure how legally you we could have in a
sense you know one administration
without a treaty can't bind subsequent
administrations and actually even with a
treaty since treaties always have a way
out you can't bind substituted
ministrations I mean one of the things
that the bush-cheney administration they
walked out of the I ABM Treaty and but
every treaty that we have you know if
the Senate wouldn't pass them if they
didn't have some provision that you
could leave them if need be so even if
we had had a treaty I don't know how you
could really effectively bind them but
you know it wasn't just the United
States the Secretary General of NATO
made public statements at the time that
NATO had reached his fullest extent and
in return for allowing a united Germany
to stay a member there would be no
further expansion this is a quote that
just recently Putin when he was talking
about you know the idea of Georgia and
Ukraine in NATO actually quoted back the
statement that Secretary General verna
had made back at that time so it wasn't
just the United States but these were
not legal commitments
given that neo has been expanded and
it's a there's something we can really
do about it at this point what would
your suggestion for u.s. foreign policy
in the region b they don't be disbanded
russia be invited to join nato well i
have i'll be talking about that in
greater detail in my in the fourth
lecture but just briefly i think
certainly there should be no further
expansion and in NATO's own interest I
don't think either Georgia or Ukraine
qualify even aside from Russian
attitudes I think either one stops where
we are and with NATO and sort of an
equally sore issue with the Russians if
we decide not to put or at least to
delay the missile interceptors in Poland
I believe that then certain other
agreements would would become possible
as far as the Russians are concerned I
think that's sort of minimal now in the
long run I think we really do have to
look at is NATO serving our interests
and I'm not sure we're taking it a good
look at that it seemed to me in the
night is that we should have been as a
United States policy shifting most
responsibility for European security
including the Balkans to Europe and
Russia including Russia and actually
using our influence to encourage the
Europeans and Russians to set up a
security organization that that would be
associated with NATO but in effect would
relieve us of much of the of the
responsibility there I think there are
more liabilities there then then assets
to be made from it and in fact by
expanding NATO the way we did we did not
even show Russians the consideration we
show Germans after World War two when
our policy was to insist that Britain
and France except Germany
as an equal in NATO now the reason was
the Soviet threat perhaps and this is
not an easy thing for them to do but
Germany which was defeated which did
attack us we use our influence to
reconcile them with the former enemies
instead with the Russians we bring in
the countries in Eastern Europe who have
grievances and obviously going to be a
problem if they're on one side or the
other and leave Russia out so I mean it
was just completely lacking in any i
would say in any vision for the sort of
world you want to have now right now
when we can't even get nato to put up an
extra thousand troops for afghanistan
it's not and it's also clear that each
individual country is going to decide
whether they support us militarily if we
need military help elsewhere i'm not
sure what advantages we're getting out
of NATO and I think we should be
thinking about well shouldn't it at
least have a European commander should
we encourage them to expand the European
defense community as part of NATO at
first and maybe that's one that you can
work a more cooperative relationship
with Russia I think right now Russia
would not want to be in NATO unless it
has some special status because they
really look at us you know and and let's
face it they're military is probably not
you know it is yet would require such a
reorganization that that's probably not
a very feasible thing but back in the
90s when it was asked well why don't we
just bring in Russia I know the Russian
answer was we're not going to stand in
line behind Bulgaria I mean they have
they do have a feeling that they are
something special and they're not going
to simply join an alliance if it means
subordination to the United States yes
wonderful lecture and it's always
fascinating to hear someone's become the
subject was actually part of the making
of the story that he's telling and
analyzing but let me uh let me ask you a
question see if I understood basically
the main thrust here it seems to me that
what you were saying is that we really
played our hand well in the Gorbachev
hero and that US policy really
contributed to the positive movement
that has happened to me in a good way
and then we come to the 1990s the
breakup of the Soviet Union and the US
starts to make blunders in its policy
toward the Soviet Union and there's a
certain implication in the way you
present the case yeah the fact that that
things got so bad in the 90s are to some
extent result of our diplomacy and then
you can cool you say that well if we had
experienced such disorder it makes sense
that the Russians would would be
tolerant of its not in favor of
something more thorat aryan if you
needed to weigh the relative importance
of the US policy in this period and
contributing to the negative outcome how
would you how much importance do you get
to it in other words to what extent are
you really holding us responsible to
some extent for what you are presenting
as an understandable I wish that there
was some way one could evaluate the
proportionate influence of various
influences I don't know any way to do it
all I can say is that i think our
policies of the 90s made it harder
internally for the democratic forces to
prevail that's number one number two I
do think that our our policies in the
90s helped contribute to the virulence
of some of the Russian nationalism that
we see today now I'm not going to say
that these things would not have
happened anyway even if our policies
have been different I don't know
obviously they are so very very
many variables there and as I mentioned
you know yesterday you know in
retrospect everything looks a little
more definite than it does at the time
because you can never really predict
precisely how things are going to play
out now I think in the case of NATO
expansion it was possible to predict
that this would play out in a negative
way both domestically in Russia and
particularly in Russia's relationship
with us on the other hand if we had
simply stopped with Poland Czech
Republic are then and hungry not
continued the process and had not
attacked Serbia it may might might have
become a non-issue so you know there are
so many variables here but basically on
your question I would say first of all I
think American policy toward Russia has
been much more important to Russia then
Russian policy has been toured the
United States we have been more or less
immune in our domestic politics from
things that they you know they have done
and in that sense whereas I think the
image of the United States and the
relationship with the United States has
played a rather large role in the image
the Russians have of themselves and and
you know both pro and con and I do think
that much of the of the nationalism does
stem from a feeling of rejection either
by the West or the United States I I
know this is your field and you can tell
me more than then I know about it but I
had the feeling for example yesterday I
talked about two chips poem which ends
but I'll see you moshe notorious of the
eighties you can only believe in Russia
Russia cannot be measured by normal
standards that this was really a
reaction to the fact that they couldn't
meet the sort of standards they saw in
Western Europe so you
ritu a feeling that you have a special
essence a special spirituality which
Outsiders really can't understand but
you're really better and that played
into Spence love is and it plays into
dusty of skis ideas and and so on but so
I think you know this this is a real
strain in Russian thinking but it did
seem to me it comes also it is enhanced
by you know a feeling of a rejection of
not being accepted and therefore you
know will never be like the West let's
be ourselves we're different we're
better in other respects you know for
different reasons Americans also seem to
have a feeling that we're special I mean
we're for democracy and if we do
something for democracy people should
understand that and should understand
we're not imperialists we don't attack
another country unless they're bad guys
and we're trying to make them Democrats
well you know so i really don't know I I
don't think there's any way one can say
because one thing you can't say things
would be markedly different if our
policy had been different but I think
that democracy and the Democratic
procedures would have had a better
chance if our policies had been
different I guess talked a lot about our
relationship with Gorbachev but what
about our relationship with Yeltsin to a
certain extent you know he was more
responsible for bringing down the party
and preserving some breaking up the
Union Gorbachev we have ties to them
where we playing both of those figures
equally in your experience or what was
the relationship well oh yeah the
relationship with Yeltsin if you mean
during the Soviet Union yeah the Bush
administration was very wary of Yeltsin
at first and he made a bad impression in
his first trip to the United States I
made a point as ambassador to
maintain a personal relationship with
him Rebecca and I would invite him and
his wife and along with course our
coffees security guard and his wife to
come to private dinners and so having
seen him when he was out I was always
able to see him and talk over the issues
when he became more and more important
and it was hard to convince Washington
that they should deal with him directly
but because they considered him very
erratic and and and and also they didn't
want to give yo Gorbachev the idea that
somehow they were playing both sides so
and as late as Bush's trip to Moscow in
July 91 by that time Nielsen had been
elected president of the russian
federation obviously he had to see him
but Yeltsin was still playing games he
kept Bush waiting for nearly 15 minutes
now you know you don't do that to the
president of the United States they have
an appointment for you know whatever it
was 115 and show up at 130 and this was
in his own office at he's yeltsin's
office so this didn't make him exactly a
favorite but you know after the coup the
attempted coup it became very clear that
the Republic's were going to go and it
looked as if you know we couldn't be
sure for a while that Russia was going
to sit still for this but then it turned
out in order to get rid of Gorbachev
Yeltsin corsa led Russia out of the
Union as well something who people
forget when they talk about russia is
being inherently imperialistic actually
Russia was the key republic that brought
down the Soviet Union but in any event
at that point it was clear we needed a
relationship with Yeltsin as I said Bush
was able to bond with him very quickly
but he needed us and we at that point
needed needed him I mean the big issue
of course aside from
continuing to reduce nuclear weapons was
to secure the ones that were there and
of course when the Soviet Union broke up
for Republic's had them and that took
some negotiation and without our
influence and a treaty that we signed
Ukraine might not have given them up
there was a lot of resistance in the
Ukrainian Parliament so I think that
there was there was a a bonding with
Yeltsin and bush after that you know I
must say from the Russian standpoint
Clinton's relationship with Yeltsin you
know Ilsan drank more than he should and
I think most Russians looked at is if
Clinton would take advantage of him it
was like rolling a drunk every time you
know they would meet a Clinton would get
his way and he could but he used it for
good things to get Russian troops out of
the Baltic States and other things we
also gave our support to get Ukraine to
send the nuclear weapons to Russia to
concentrate them in one country so it
was a mutually it was a mutually
advantageous relationship for a while
and yet when it came later to things
like NATO expansion which you know
Yeltsin really felt was although at one
point he said it's okay he was a sort
that would spout all these things in
fact he considered it very much an
insult and felt this very deeply on the
other hand he didn't want a public spat
with Clinton and so as I'd say it was
sort of from the Russian standpoint it
was the like Clinton was able to roll
the drunk every time and end up with his
wallet
I just want to remind you that part 3
and 4 will be on the tenth and eleventh
of memory and we'll continue this
fascinating inside view of debunking of
the myths surrounding the end of the
Cold War breakup of the sudden thank you
very much
you